wie geht er damit um das ist natürlich
eine tragödie für unseren ort junger
mann junger familien fall wird und
unsere wunderschönen badestrand sein
leben gelassen um seine kinder zu retten
es ist natürlich schwer wir haben alle
persönlich gekannt also die kamera hat
in den kameraden der freiwilligen
feuerwehr
er war vor einigen jahren selbst bei uns
aktiv dabei und das liegt natürlich sehr
schwer für die kameraden kameraden die
gestern im einsatz gewesen sind um ihnen
dann eben noch zu retten leider ist aus
der rettung bergung geworden über den
gesundheitszustand der kinder kann ich
tatsächlich nicht viel auskunft geben
ich weiß dass sie gestern mit lasuren
und schürfwunden und natürlich
psychologischer unterstützung ins
krankenhaus gekommen sind und am tag
danach über den vater verloren hat es
ist einen anschub allgemein bekannt dass
es diese gefährlichen strömungen an
ihren stränden gibt es das eine gefahr
die einwohner kennen und die urlauber
auch kennen müssen also da muss man
glaube ich richtig stellen dass es keine
gefährlichen strömungen am strand von
ahrenshoop gibt es gibt strömungen und
es gibt ja einfach gewisse windstärken
wettersituationen wie gestern die
besonders stark sind wir hatten gestern
sechs bis sieben windstärken hier vor
ort das macht sich auf der ostsee
natürlich besonders bemerkbar
hinzu kommt dass wir bei den
wellenbrechern natürlich eine gewisse
sogwirkung haben
dort brechen die wellen die wellen gehen
dort andere wege schlagen auch über die
wellenbrecher das wasser ist dort sehr
tief und das führt natürlich dazu dass
man auch als geübter und guter schwimmer
schwierigkeiten bekommen kann
der strand von ahrenshoop ist sicher das
ist ganz wichtig dass auch zu vermitteln
wir müssen nur auch darauf acht geben
wir haben ein hinweisschild an den
strand aufgängen dass eine unfallgefahr
am wellenbrecher aber auch an den buhnen
herrscht man muss also mit besonderer
gedacht mit besonderem bedacht aber auch
mit besonderen ich sag mal feingefühl
ins wasser gehen immer darüber
nachdenken wann ist die situation
vielleicht doch zu gefährlich uns allen
wie gut geschulter schwimmen bin ich
einfach ostsee die ostsee ist ein mehr
muss man einfach so sagen